you know and this is what i've been
objecting to with regards to this
group mentality from the beginning it's
it it seems to me that it's fundamental
danger
the fundamental danger is the
devaluation of the
of the sacredness of the individual as
the primary category you replace that by
group identity you have no idea what
kind of devil you're messing with or or
maybe you do to some degree you
experienced it a bit because you messed
about with that devil and you got
tempted and 7 000 people told you you
were right
it's like imagine you're a political
leader
okay now imagine 30 million people tell
you that you're right and they chant
that in a mob
and they do that everywhere you go if
that's what happened in germany
and then you play to the crowd
you're that actor you play to the crowd
and you get hungry and hungrier for that
validation
and you train yourself to say anything
the crowd demands no matter how dark
right right
right
and i i find it extremely worrying which
is why i speak very very loudly in the
way that i do especially online because
that's exactly what we're starting to
see online people saying whatever it
takes
to get that same level of validation and
affirmation every single time
[Music]
welcome to episode 120 of the michaela
peterson podcast
this is an absolutely
incredible episode it's with africa
brooke and my dad
africa is one of the most eloquent
guests i've had on and her interaction
with my dad was heart-wrenching she
wrote the viral article
why i'm leaving the cult of wokeness
which i've linked below
africa brooks spoke about what made her
write that article and the effects it
had on her life afterwards we ended up
discussing wokeness to politics religion
racism how to stop your ego from
destroying your life
how to stop narcissism from destroying
your soul
it was mainly an episode between africa
and my dad i surprised her with my dad
to be honest but i enjoyed it immensely
this is not one to miss
also i'm staying in nashville
nashville's awesome franklin's amazing
too but i'm very allergic to it it's
just outside of nashville so back to a
condo for me surrounded by cement
if you enjoy this episode hit subscribe
[Music]
africa brook welcome to my podcast
thank you i'm i'm so thrilled that we're
able to do this and i think the timing
is perfect actually because i know we've
tried to do it a few times before um but
there's something about this time
specifically just the timing of this
that feels
that feels very very aligned so i'm very
very happy to be here with both of you
thank you
maybe we had to cancel a few times
because my dad had to join who knows
right i i think say i think that might
have been it
okay before we get started um
one i want to read a paragraph from the
article you wrote that went viral
and then i'm going to get you to
introduce yourself and then we can get
started
so this is this is why i'm leaving the
cult of wokeness
i can no longer be an active participant
in any culture or movement that
encourages group think outrage on demand
fear and violence revamped segregation
fabricating history cancellations masked
as accountability self-centeredness
normalization of racism towards white
people the disempowerment of black
people masked as social justice the
constant redefining of existing language
ignoring self-responsibility
constant pathologizing oppressed versus
oppressor mentality and the prefresh
i almost did the entire thing with no
errors and the pressure to conform and
comply it's exhausting and honestly i
have better things to do with my time
not to mention it's killing us
okay
now you can do your intro
so my name is africa brooke and i am a
writer i'm a consultant and i'm also a
speaker there are many other things that
i do but that's the best way to kind of
encapsulate everything
so my journey into the work that i do
now which is specifically focusing on
the costs and the effects of
self-sabotage and self-censorship began
about five years ago um we could go into
this later or i can kind of just give a
little bit of a brief um
a brief summary now um it became like it
began five years ago when i got sober
and me getting sober wasn't just a
decision that i made overnight and then
now i have five years of sobriety it was
actually a very grueling soul destroying
process and i had relapsed seven times
before that between the ages of 19 to 24
and i always say that what was different
about that final time in 2016 when i was
just so physically exhausted with that
cycle
is that i became curious about what that
cycle actually was i started to get
curious about human behavior about the
concept of self-sabotage which is
something that i discovered just through
research and wanting to understand my
own behavior
and it's it's what leads me to the work
that i do now where
i ended up looking at my own subjective
experience but i ended up speaking to
hundreds now thousands of people
um speaking to academics speaking to
people that were addicts speaking to
people in my family who also experienced
addiction and it slowly started to
become something that felt like a
responsibility for me to
give people this information and now i
don't just focus on the self the
individual i now look at self-sabotage
and self-censorship through the lens of
the collective which is where my letter
comes from
and it kind of speaks to that
okay so when is this letter from and how
many people have read this this letter
was published on january the 2nd 2021
and i had been writing it for about
six months but
you know
two years in the making if you will but
when i published it it was only to a
very small newsletter of mine maybe 2
000 people
and it just it just took off and by
month 6 it had been read by 3.5 million
people and i mean it's it's not a short
letter it's 4 000 words which for anyone
to have read even half of that in in the
time that we're in right now where
people prefer anything that is short and
quick
um it really tells me something and now
it's been read by over four million
people
wow
okay
so before you you wrote this you said
why i'm leaving the cult of wokeness so
what were your beliefs
prior to the publication of this letter
and how they changed
that's a good question let me just sit
with that for a second what were my
beliefs prior to this letter
i wouldn't even be able to sort of list
them
in a very neat way
um because i thought i was a very
balanced person i had never over
identified with any kind of movement i
had never
um seen myself as a firm part of social
justice if you will i i had friends that
were part of those movements etc but i
had never seen myself in that way
but the thing is
you
don't often realize just how much
a label is impacting you until you see
yourself act in a way that you wouldn't
expect so in terms of beliefs for
example i didn't believe that all white
people were racist even though this was
common rhetoric that i was hearing and
to the point where it was just kind of
normal and expected for me to hear
people say things like that you know but
then in my mind i would say okay they
don't actually mean every white person
they're just talking about the system of
whiteness etc cetera so i had been in
certain spaces long enough to kind of
understand what people
really do mean
um so it's not as if i thought in that
way but
for me the fact that
it was even normal for me to hear things
like that is what started to make me a
little bit uncomfortable um
my beliefs were still very much what
they are now but i think the issue was
that i was afraid to actually voice what
my true values were i was afraid that if
i
say actually no i don't agree with that
person who's on the left and i actually
very much agree with that person who is
on quote unquote the right that i
shouldn't be thinking that way that it
was i was betraying the movement in some
kind of way you know that because i'm
black because i'm women because etc etc
i shouldn't be thinking in this way so i
would say my beliefs weren't really
different from what they are now but i
was holding back from actually
expressing my true values and my truest
thoughts how did you how do you think
you found what your true values and your
true thoughts were and and how did you
come to the realization that you weren't
you know that you were implicitly
participating in something akin to
self-censorship
yes you know i think it's when i
realized that i was crossing my own
boundaries
that's when i was reminded of what my
true values were because i value honesty
even when it's uncomfortable
and that's something that i've always
spoken about publicly in in in many
different ways and talking about other
things but essentially
i i believe in honesty even when it's
deeply uncomfortable but i wasn't being
honest myself maybe behind closed doors
i was maybe behind closed doors i was
listening to thinkers like yourself
jordan who i had been told that i
shouldn't listen to you
uh because of you know certain identity
markers like the ones i've mentioned
black women etc um
so it's when i realized that i was
crossing my own boundaries and it was
actually making me quite sick because i
think
for many people many people might
resonate but when you suppress something
long enough it has to go somewhere so if
you if you just hold it and hold it and
hold it you can get physically sick
and migraines are something that i've
been guessing since i was about 11
actually and from about
2019 all throughout 2020 last year i was
getting severe migraines and this was
when i was internally battling with just
censoring myself and feeling like it's
wrong for me to think these things let
alone express them publicly
um
so i would say that i i was reminded of
what my values were when i realized that
i had been crossing my boundary okay so
i got a couple of questions about that
so if i got your story right so far
you you said that
you had
more or less implicitly and perhaps
somewhat explicitly
accepted
a version of yourself that was
in alignment with
with group identity categorizations you
said well i'm black i'm a woman i'm
young um so i have to
so the proper set of opinions for me to
have an express is this set
and then you noticed that
you felt or thought
at least some things that were in
contradiction to that and then you
noticed that you were afraid to express
those
and then you started to realize that
perhaps the fact that you weren't
allowed to express those or to explore
them was associated with well with
stress at least and and then with
whatever the contribution of the stress
might be to your vulnerability so
exacerbating your so and then
so was it and then did your explicit
your new explicit beliefs start to to
develop as a consequence of that
and and what changed for for you
what changed for me was a very was a
very very very specific uh moment that i
mentioned in my letter as well it was
last year when i would say this was may
may or june
um
when
you know the racial uprising in the u.s
was happening george floyd um his story
the story of his killing
spread all across the world essentially
and
this was a time where i found myself
feeling extremely challenged i found
myself feeling the pressure
to perform in a way that was identical
to other black people that i wasn't
allowed to actually sit back and say
wait what what actually happened what is
what is the story there was a very
specific story that i was supposed to
take on board and i was supposed to
outwardly what was that story that you
were supposed to take on board exactly
right so the story specifically that i
felt i needed to take on board was that
black people were being hunted down in
the u.s and that racial divide um
the current racial divide that we're
seeing in the us and bear in mind i
don't live in the us i'm in i'm in
london i'm in the uk i've never been to
the us my entire life i'm not uh i i
wouldn't be able to tell you the ins and
outs of the politics of america
um
black people are being hunted down
and as a black person it is your
responsibility to speak against white
supremacy it is your responsibility to
turn to every single white person in
your life and ask them why they are not
speaking about this very specific
situation in the us
so it was it was along those lines but
it wasn't just happening online it was
also happening offline
um and i felt this pressure and you know
what i i'll be very honest i at the same
time as me feeling that pressure i felt
a deep sense of connection to people
that looks like me it was a very
emotional time i felt like we were all
coming together and there's this sort of
unity that i had never experienced
before yes there was a lot of anger a
lot of frustration and i think both can
be very essential ingredients depending
on the context
but soon after that
i started to feel uncomfortable because
there seemed like there was there wasn't
any room for questioning you just had to
follow what you were being told to do
you just had to play along to the script
and if you were white you were supposed
to um
apologize for all the sins of your
ancestors and the sins that you are
going to commit yourself in future
because
you're white right so do you start to
wonder then maybe
that
the point of the moral outrage is to
encourage the following that you were
finding psychologically objectionable
rather than to redress the hypothetical
social wrongs that were being uh
that are being manifested
is that right
yes that's that's exactly it that's
exactly it and
the specific incident
that i'm talking about here was born
from that so my following was pretty big
at that time i would say 50 000 or so
which is still a lot of people
and i was re-sharing a lot of um posts
that other people were sharing as well
uh about why it's important especially
if you're white to speak up at this time
etc etc
and
what's interesting about this is that
i've never been someone that will just
instantly share something or say
something because i feel that i should
which is why when michaela you asked
before what were your beliefs i i could
easily say that i feel like i've always
believed the same things but it's about
what i was actually expressing outwardly
right
um
so i was sharing a lot of things because
of the emotions that i felt because of
the narrative that is a black person
this is your opportunity to stand for
something you know
um
re-sharing a lot of things
and there was a man who sent me a
message and this wasn't an unkind
message or anything like that when i
look at it now in retrospect he was just
asking if
everything that i'm sharing and
everything that i'm saying right now
um
is the best approach to take i i believe
this was a man who was familiar with my
work before so he he felt as if there
was something out of character
so he asked me if this was the best
approach to take this was a private
message
and instantly it didn't even cross my
mind to
have a conversation with him privately
my instant thought which is a thought i
had never in my entire life had before
was
how dare you question a black woman in
that way that was my that was my first
thought i've never i've never thought in
that way before i'm open to having
conversations difficult conversations
i've been doing it for years
but in that moment because there was
just such a perfect environment that had
been created
that was my first thought so i
screenshotted that message and i posted
it onto my feed to my audience for all
to see
um and of course i got exactly what i
needed in that moment i got exactly what
my ego was looking for
thousands of people uh telling me that
this man was wrong uh people telling me
that i shouldn't have to educate anyone
you know that's kind of a common social
justice language no one is here to
educate you especially or to do unpaid
emotional labor
right there we go emotional labor
especially because i fall under certain
identity markers which are seen as more
important than others you know a black
woman shouldn't have to educate you
so
that was about 20 minutes
20 very very long minutes and thousands
of people sort of swarming it was a very
very visceral
and
the validation and affirmation that i
felt in that moment was like nothing i i
had experienced in a while
and
it was almost like an out of body
experience and maybe someone else
hearing this might think well it's just
a [ __ ] instagram post but i was
seeing myself in a way that i had never
seen myself before
it's almost like i was hovering over
myself holding my phone seeing a flood
of this validation coming in so i
publicly shamed this man who had simply
just asked a question you know
um
and i didn't i didn't even have to deal
with it it's not
and it's really important for me to talk
about these things in a very um in a
very open and honest way but in that
moment i i dehumanized him he wasn't he
wasn't a human being he was just that's
just a question that i received and i
didn't have to process it ask myself why
do i feel uncomfortable is this man is
this person not owed some kind of
response or not at all he messaged me in
a private place
should i not give him the respect of
doing the same no i didn't
um so within that 20 minutes i think
about six to seven thousand people
commented or liked this post and
something just felt as you know with the
same intensity that it felt
validating and affirming i just felt
sick
it was it was just like that
as if i i had snapped out of something
and i know what that something was
because obviously now i know i had been
you know
almost ideologically possessed and i had
no idea
you know um and what an appeal to
narcissism you have it's stunning it's
it's and i'm amazed that you it's so
interesting that you experienced that in
all its potency
right the elevation of your opinion to
unquestionable the social validation of
that extraordinarily powerful and
tempting
and then to notice that it actually made
you sick that's really something
right that is that's really impressive
yeah i don't think people are built for
the level that social media can give you
at the moment like six thousand or seven
thousand people all agreeing with you
it's really hard to psychologically
overcome that right in 20 minutes
in 20 minutes which on social media it's
it's two minutes
if you're sitting there and you're
holding your phone and because i'm a
very visual person sometimes i picture
this
being surrounded by that amount of
people who are telling you that you've
done a great job that man he was wrong
he shouldn't have spoken to you in that
way that speaks to a part of me that
needs that a part of me that needs that
in a way that is completely unrelated to
what was actually happening in that
moment
but that moment that i felt sick i just
felt like
africa what are you what are you doing
what are you actually doing and i
removed the post
um what what were you doing what were
you actually doing
what do you think it was that made you
sick
[Music]
i was performing
i was performing i was performing and i
know performance very very well having
have
gone through what i did with alcohol and
my
my father when we were growing up he was
also an alcoholic we grew up in a very
very abusive home he was physically
abusive and which is where
self-censorship actually came from for
me from a very young age because when
you're in such an uncertain environment
you you learn how to navigate it pretty
quickly you learn how to censor yourself
so that you can stay safe
um so i learned how to perform from a
very very young age to perform whatever
version is gonna is gonna make him happy
whatever version is gonna make him less
likely to hit me or my siblings or my
mom
and in that moment and i've only said
this out loud maybe twice but in that
moment
with that man that kind of
awakening uh that very rude awakening i
felt like i was performing the version
of myself that would stop me from
getting hit or mobbed
by the public
hey folks this episode is brought to you
by superspeciosa superspeciosa
is a kratom company
like so kratom is a herb related to the
coffee plants
the leaves or extracts from the leaves
like this
have been used as a stimulant and a
sedative it works on opiate receptors in
the brain so it's been used to treat
chronic pain digestive ailments and aid
in withdrawal from opiate dependency i
always advocate for dietary changes to
enhance mood before anything else diet
exercise infrared saunas avoiding
inflammatory foods which are kind of
like poison
but if you're still having trouble or if
you have physical pain and you've
already tried other ways to deal with
it
kratom might be worth a shot it's great
for energy support some people will use
it as a substitute for coffee or as a
pre-workout some people use it to manage
stress and to help them relax
superspeciosa has different strains
this one's red
some help you relax some give you energy
the most important part of super species
and the reason i really like them is
because their kratom is reliable
third-party lab tested and approved
under the american kratom association's
quality standards program
in these capsules
it's only kratom that's the other reason
i like it kratom
in a capsule
remember because this works on opiate
receptors
it can cause addiction if you overdo it
so do your research google everything
you take be super paranoid about what
you put in your body i wish i'd known
about something like kratom when i was
getting off morphine for my multiple
joint replacements it would have been
super helpful
go to
get super leaf dot com
slash mp
and enter code mp for 20 off if you want
to give these bad boys a shot
that's getsuperleaf.com mp code mp for
20 off enjoy the rest of the episode so
you removed the post
and then
what happened afterwards where did this
go
i removed the post and
i just retracted internally but
externally i just removed the post and i
pretended that it had never happened
a lot of my the work that i do is public
a lot of the conversations i have are
public so i kind of just continued
but behind the scenes
this is when i started to
really want to understand exactly what
had happened in that moment what had i
been experiencing for the past two years
um
and that's when my letter started taking
shape
and my letter was just a journal entry
to begin with just writing it to myself
so that i could say that i'm done i i
don't want to play this game anymore um
this game is not just making me sick but
it's making all of us
sick
um
and writing has always been the way that
i'm able to really make sense of how i
feel without feeling like i need to
necessarily
express it vocally
and
i i would say that's what really saved
me from slipping into shame because
everything that had happened with that
man it was a
it could have been very easy to shame
myself
or to
either just pretend it never happened
which is something that i see a lot
actually
um
just denial just the theme of denial
runs through everything that i'm seeing
play out in the culture
i see things like that all the time
where someone will
publicly shame someone or they will
misrepresent someone and then maybe find
out that they were wrong in a very
public way as well and then they'll just
pretend that it never happened you know
and they get to move on
but that person did they get to move on
you know when i think of that man who i
have reached out to since
um
he doesn't necessarily get to move on in
the same way i did because if i've
shared his handle maybe there's someone
that has me on such a pedestal that they
feel that africa
shouldn't have had to go through this so
i'm going to you know i i don't know
make sure that this man pays or it
happens all the time it happens all the
time right
um
so behind the scenes that's when i
started writing this letter
do you have
i'm sure that this is going to resonate
with people this conversation um do you
have suggestions for people who might be
feeling that kind of like
i know what you mean when you do
something that you're like your soul
doesn't agree with and it's like i call
it i think what i get is some sort of
existential horror
it's just like yeah it's just like
everywhere it's like you're going in the
wrong direction of reality or something
so if
if people are stuck in that
and are scared
how how do those people try and stop and
switch to going in the right direction
hopefully that made us some semblance of
sense right right and you know what
michaela i wish there was a
you can imagine that i get asked that
question
times
and i think we want a simple answer
don't we we we want just one answer
that
i i don't think there's one answer
um part of it is to
to
try to listen to what you say
to what you're saying and see if it
makes you feel stronger or weaker yeah
like each word is like a stepping stone
through a swamp
you know and and if it's the right word
then you step on it it feels
secure and stable compared to the
territory around it and you test that
out
and you dare to
see if that's the way you think as
opposed to that persona that you're
putting on for public adulation and
protection
right that's the temptation of the actor
so in in the movie pinocchio when
pinocchio is trying to stop lying and to
become a real boy
he faces two major temptations apart
from lying
one is to
be a victim
and the other is to be an actor
it took me a long time to to figure out
why being an actor was a temptation
but you put your finger on it with your
description
it's to adopt a set of rules that will
well appeal to narcissistic inflation
something like that it's
it's there's a terrible totalitarian
danger in that
it's terrible
yeah so yes and and that's my suspicions
are that's what you were reacting to so
viscerally that you were participating
in that and you had your reasons but
um you mentioned something that i think
maybe the three of us could discuss that
would be
would be
interesting
you know this idea about
all white people being racist
so
so i kind of wondered about that as a
psychologist but more broadly
because maybe you could say
well are all people
racist and here's here's what i mean by
that
well we all have an in-group preference
now what that group might be you know it
might be you and the person you love
it might be you and your family might be
you in your town it might be you and
your state or your country it might be
you and your race you know that who that
in group is can vary
but
we do have preferences for people and we
do have in-group preferences and the
corollary of that is that we have
out-group
uh skepticism and maybe fear and maybe
disgust and all of that and
from what i've been able to understand
anthropologically that's more or less a
human universal you know as
as different peoples have been
brought around the world into
global
community let's say
one of the things that anthropologists
have found is that it's it's almost
always the case that
any given tribe of people will use the
word that refers to human beings to
their tribe
and some other word to everyone else
and so
it's possible that that's a deep
tendency that we all have to fight
against and i mean there's part of the
reason these ideas are so compelling to
people and able to possess them the
wokeness ideas let's say to use a
casual category is that
you know
they contain an element of truth
you know
people have it in group preference
that can easily be distorted into
something that's that's quite akin to
racism i mean you even see that in
chimpanzees for example they'll go on
raiding
forays into neighboring territories and
if they outnumber the males do this if
they outnumber
the
foreigners that they come across they
will tear them to pieces
so it's yeah yeah that was a stunning
discovery
lovely that primatologists made jane
goodall's team [ __ ] discovered that in
the 70s it was a real shock
right so they're trying to find all the
nice chimps yeah well they're like oh
they just rip each other down through
the shreds well okay yeah exactly well
no one had had any inkling
previous to that that that human
tendency for for war
you know
broadly speaking was so deep that it was
even shared by our you know closest
animal
uh
relative so this is very deep so you
know the idea that racism
and in-group preference all of that is
something that human beings struggle
with is true and then you say well
you know you twist out of it you say
well that's particularly true of white
people because they hold the power
it's like well you know it's an
interesting proposition
but the question is well
if it's true exactly how it's how is it
true and what's its limits and
you know how does that play out in the
case of other
races or groups asians for example
um
um and what are the dangers of putting
the idea that way like and
what makes you so sure that that's also
not true of your group and
how does power play into that like these
are all these are all genuine questions
that we should be asking ourselves
instead of
like hammering home the idea that we
have the answer to this it's like well
you know
you you you you said you know you you
got elevated as a black woman
in this well it's very difficult to see
that
to not see that as an exacerbation of
your in-group preference and then an
exaggeration of that implicit or
explicit racism on your part and i think
that's part of what you were rebelling
against yes yes yes yes
and and you know what the questions that
you were just asking before those are
the exact questions that i had just
simple questions
um
and it started to signal again that
something wasn't right here that i
couldn't even just ask the simplest
questions or at least felt that i
couldn't i could have
but i was much more scared of the
consequences of asking the questions
than leading with the curiosity of
getting some kind of answer right
um
and in my letter michaela you read this
pot out earlier about
the disempowerment of black people
that's how i started to feel extremely
disempowered
you know even when people would say
things like yeah it's because white
people have all the power
according to who and in what context are
we talking about
which one is the world you are which
ones
right i had
i had an experience like that um
not
exactly like that it was like that but
for me and i was taking sciences um
because i'd switched out of humanities
because there was a lot of you know i
was taking a course on homer and it was
homer through the feminist lens and i
was like that's not what i came that's
how i paid you guys for so i switched
into sciences and about every couple
months somebody would come in and they'd
say okay for all the women in the room i
know you've had you've had a much harder
time getting to where you are than the
men have
and i was just like are you
are you telling me i'm stupid like what
exactly are you saying here and how dare
you suggest that it was just it was like
insulting in kind of a condescending way
which was the complete opposite of
whatever they were well and maybe it
wasn't the opposite of what they were
trying to do
um but
yeah it's condescending and irritating
yeah well it means
well think about what that does in some
sense it makes your generic femininity
and your generic vulnerability
far more important
than your individual particularity
you know and this is what i've been
objecting to with regards to this
group mentality from the beginning it's
it it seems to me that it's
fundamental danger
the fundamental danger is the
devaluation of the
of the sacredness of the individual as
the primary category you replace that by
group identity you have no idea what
kind of devil you're messing with or or
maybe you do to some degree you
experienced it a bit because you messed
about with that devil and you got
tempted and 7 000 people told you you
were right
it's like imagine you're a political
leader
okay now imagine 30 million people tell
you that you're right and they chant
that in a mob
and they do that everywhere you go
that's what happened in germany
and then you play to the crowd
you you're that actor you play to the
crowd and you get hungry and hungrier
for that validation
and you train yourself to say anything
the crowd demands no matter how dark
right right
right
and i i find it extremely worrying which
is why i speak very very loudly in the
way that i do especially online because
that's exactly what we're starting to
see online people saying whatever it
takes
to get that same level of validation and
affirmation every single time and
when we go back to the question that you
asked earlier of what did you then do
after you removed that post there were
also other things that i did
um
behind the scenes which is where you
come in again jordan i thought to myself
okay so
who was some of the people that i
discarded in the past because i was told
to not because it was a conscious
decision that i made on my part what was
i told that i shouldn't read that i
shouldn't agree with that i shouldn't
listen to
um and i specifically started started
listening to speakers i i would say
actually this was
more so after that specific incident
online but i had started doing this from
late 2019
just challenging myself to sit through
conversations being had by people i
would never have listened to people that
are let's say on quote unquote the right
which is interesting because i've never
identified as being part on the left
it's assumed it's assumed because
because of all of those identity markers
and the things that i might agree with
mostly the things that i'm most aware of
it's just assumed to the point where
maybe
i started to assume that about myself
which is why i had resistance to the
right
um
no michaela go go
no no i i just liked your
that was all that was all you go ahead
but it's um
and and also there's a cultural aspect
to this so i was born and raised in
zimbabwe that's that's where i'm from
that's home that's still the first
language that i speak at home with my
family
um and i left that at the age of nine
i'm 20 i'm 29 now
and
over identifying with the political
party is just not
really culturally a thing no one even
says things you know like they're on the
left or the right or they're zanu pf or
mdc those are the political parties but
they're not um
it's something that i i see more in the
west if you will like a you know on
dating apps people will have left
leftist or lefty or things
things like that they've become markers
of religious affiliation
yes and that's also a terrible thing
because when politics becomes religion
it's gone too far
and that's part of the danger of the
loss of religion is that you don't you
can't get rid of it it crops up
somewhere something else gets inflated
into religious dimensions and that's
when paul and that's when when things
are you're supposed to render unto
caesar what are caesars and render unto
god what are gods what is god's
and if you render
that's weird that's weird okay really
and if you read it yeah really if you
render unto god
if you render unto caesar what is god's
then caesar gets inflated into a god
and and and that's another danger and an
existential danger for everyone like we
we we have this rational idea that we
can dispense with our religious values
but by definition our religious values
are our deepest values
by definition
and
you have to have deep values or you're
disintegrated and aimless
and they're going to come from somewhere
and be placed somewhere
and if they slip out of
a domain of religion that's set aside
specially for that
then it's easy for the political to
become inflated
and that's it's we don't want that
that's that's
that's not good
so
okay so that's not happening in zimbabwe
so no and you see it here
oh i see it oh i see it okay second ad
what here i am again with my dinosaur
shirt i wanted to talk to you guys about
nordvpn i use vpns when i'm traveling
which i'm doing a lot
did you know they don't do disney plus
in serbia
well they do with nordvpn can't believe
there are areas of the world that ban
disney disney did you also know they're
putting trigger warnings in front of
some disney movies anyway this isn't
supposed to be about disney or getting
access to disney well maybe it's kind of
about getting access to disney it's
about nordvpn nordvpn not only are they
sponsoring me which is fantastic but
they do allow me to get into netflix and
disney wherever i am if i'm somewhere
sketchy i also can protect myself from
getting my information stolen by using
nordvpn in said sketchy areas or if you
are doing something sketchy on the
internet a vpn is also probably what
you're looking for
i also really like nordvpn because it
has the fastest vpn in the world it
doesn't slow down my internet when
streaming in different countries like
other vpns i've used nordvpn is
something i would really recommend vpns
come in handy in restaurants airports
other countries that block certain
websites and to hide your information
when you want to i have a fantastic code
for 73 off annually for them which is
pretty huge 73 off at nordvpn.com
tmpp
like the michaela peterson podcast code
tmpp for 73 off that's nordvpn.com
tmpp
code tmpp for 73 off annually enjoy the
rest of the episode
so what i what i decided to do was to
just listen to different people and i
remember listening to some of your some
of your lectures jordan i wouldn't be
able to tell you which one specifically
because i listened to so many but
in the beginning
and this was still happening last summer
as well
i was sitting there just watching alone
and i remember even for a few months
feeling like i'm doing something wrong
and this was you probably were you
probably were
[Laughter]
and this was such a bizarre
feeling because again
maybe i would have experienced this
differently if i had family identified
with being on quote unquote the left or
being
a feminist i've never identified in that
way or just any of these things that
would kind of make sense for me to fully
physically reject what i'm watching
right now but i had always considered
myself to be quite quite balanced right
but it took me sitting down listening to
you amongst other people to really
realize just how sucked into these echo
chambers i had been because i felt as
though i was betraying
the movement in some kind of way and you
know what's so interesting when i say
the movement i wouldn't be able to tell
you which one any pic pick any that i'm
betraying some kind of
bigger collective purpose why did you
just why did you continue why did you do
it why did you continue and how did you
know that that voice wasn't the true
voice of your conscience yeah that's a
good question
that's a good question
i knew it because
that the discomfort that i felt
wasn't anything compared to the sickness
that i had felt for the past two years
actually being immersed in those spaces
and more than that
everything that not only you were saying
and that other thinkers were saying i
remember listening to larry elder for
example
and feeling the very same things if not
more because i was receiving
certain information from a black man and
i'd never heard
anyone speak in that kind of way before
in a very objective way talking about
certain data as to why maybe he doesn't
think there's systemic racism in the u.s
et cetera et cetera just data-driven
research
and i i still felt that i couldn't
it
the cognitive dissonance to just put it
very simply the cognitive dissonance was
intense
but i sat with it because i'm very
familiar with discomfort i always see my
sobriety and the journey to getting
sober as the foundation that holds me in
place when i'm feeling any kind of
discomfort because i
when i go back to getting sober for
example that final eighth time
i felt i felt so uncomfortable there was
nothing
in that moment there was nothing
empowering about it it wasn't this
profound decision that i made and that
now i live a sober life it was i had no
other choice otherwise i was going to be
sick for the rest of my life yeah i
think you make you make a choice like
that not in pride but in abject humility
yes
yes
yes and i see that process that i took
myself through
um of kind of
giving myself back to myself is the way
that i think of it you know sitting
through those lectures hearing you talk
um
because i had had an experience in
relation to you years before where i had
made a firm decision that i would never
in my life
listen to anything this man has to say
[Music]
[Laughter]
based on a three-minute clip mind you
do you remember what it was that i said
that was so profoundly irritating
i mean there's many
can you tell me what can you tell me
what that was
of course
you were talking about the gender pay
gap um and this was a this was part of a
longer interview the you know the
interview that you had with kevin newman
and this was a clip three minute clip
you were talking about the gender pay
gap and you were saying that you know
paraphrasing here but that the reason
for most women is because most women are
agreeable most women don't negotiate etc
etc i i believe that was essentially
essentially giving
people
options as to why it could be that
there's this thing that exists or
doesn't exist and i didn't even finish
the clip i didn't even finish the three
minute clip but based on the things that
another out of context clip that i had
seen before
and the way that i'd heard your name
being spoken of before in in the context
of the trans conversation that was
happening around that time 2018 right
exactly um
again i was watching this clip
and it's almost like i wasn't even
listening to what you were saying i had
already decided that i i i don't like
this man because someone that i trust
has told me that i shouldn't like him so
therefore you know the decision is made
why do i even have to finish that video
right and it was just right and it was
just normal well you know we use
heuristics like that all the time you
know and it's easy to get caught up in
them because well you can't listen to
everyone
and so you kind of have to make a snap
judgment about almost everyone and and
this and the default is
you don't listen because there's like
seven billion people so obviously you're
not listening to most of them so you
don't need much of an excuse and it's
really easy for that to get and i mean
it's not like i haven't experienced that
like you know on my podcast you know i
invite people on abigail schreier for
example she wrote i don't remember
her the name of her most recent book but
it's a investigation into the downside
of the
of the rush to make everything gender
fluid essentially
and i was terrified when when i had her
on i mean i wasn't rather irrelevant
irreversible damage yeah
you know i want to have andy noah on my
podcast but that also makes me nervous
too and you know because he's tired with
the fascist brush and
and then you get it's guilt by
association and that might have been
part of what you were feeling so
those so you think well you need a
simplifying heuristic and part of that
is well that most people aren't worth
listening to and he's definitely not
worth listening to and right
and then that can so easily become
politicized and once it is especially
when the political has become religious
it's really really hard
to overcome that
yeah and so it really is you know a lot
of the things that the radical left are
pointing out are in some sense universal
human failings
and so they have that truth about them i
mean because we could ask ourselves
um
given the implicit tendency for human
beings to have a pronounced in-group
preference and the potential we have for
violence against out-group members
how do we all address our
proclivity to damn the foreigner
okay that's a really important question
i mean like i've got a good i've got a
good answer okay let me add the one the
one end to that and then the next thing
is well
we all have these proclivities how are
they exacerbated by
by power and
privilege right those are good questions
but as soon as we make it instantly
racist well then we can't even ask the
damn questions properly anymore so mick
sorry
my joke is over now
i'm sorry i stomped all over your timely
juice you stomped all over my tiny
little joke
uh i was thinking about that question
earlier though uh if everyone has these
tendencies which they certainly do i've
noticed that if i have a guest on my
podcast and i think my audience is
fairly open-minded but then i'll have a
guest on that and they'll hate them
and they'll be like well you can't just
even if you don't agree with them maybe
and maybe they are wrong but like you
can't just cancel people because they
don't agree with you because you're
doing exactly the same thing that the
people you're complaining about well you
know and also maybe your maybe your
stupid opinions aren't right they're
probably not right and like are you so
sure your life is going so much the way
you want it to go and you're such a
bloody paragon of virtue and the light
is shining out every orifice that
everything you think can say is correct
and everyone who disabuses you of your
notions is evil you're really so sure of
that are you
so you know you wander around and you
think god maybe i should listen to this
person because i'm such an ignorant
bastard and i'm so full of malevolence
and maybe they'll drop one thing on me
that won't make me like miserable and
doomed to hell and to drag everyone else
there too
that's yeah well
you know i i
i felt something similar when when i
finally leaned into listening to you
properly because what was interesting
even after that moment in 2018 watching
that three-minute clip deciding this man
is evil i want nothing to do with him
ever again and of course i didn't think
i would ever have anything to do with
that yeah look what happened
infiltrated yeah right um
people
in my especially people that were
not really connected to the digital
world a lot of my
a lot of older men in my life for
example and women in my life would
always tell me
to read your book it's honestly i people
would always say to me africa you will
really love this book i would have
friends of mine send me lectures i think
you're really going to like this and i
would just completely ignore it and in
my mind i'd be thinking
what am i what am i going to find what
am i supposed to like because again i
have this idea of you built up in my
head so i'm finding it very confusing
that people that know me very well are
telling me that there's something that
i'm going to like
right yeah what they are confusing but
again for years what the hell
years i ignored it
so when i started watching your lectures
late 2019 and last summer as well in the
beginning i could notice myself
listening to you
and finding
waiting
for a moment where i could say aha see
see right i
i knew i was right
and you know what i waited i went that
moment never came
that moment never came that comes from
me
and
that again so it's like there wasn't one
moment of being awake and then it's done
so many little tiny seemingly
insignificant moments where i'm just
sitting here by my sofa
just watching and listening observing
myself waiting you know for that
confirmation that i'm right
and then it never coming and then i have
to deal with that and then so
again my curiosity i finally allowed
myself to be curious again and now
jordan i can say you have been one of
the most influential people to me for so
many reasons reasons i couldn't even
mention right now um
but
to be able to have the conversations
that i do now publicly
you have
and i i i could have never
never imagined this ever in my entire
life this is
things like this don't just happen and
i can't tell you this
oh no
thank you just
thank you
thank you you got him
it's a pleasure
it's a rough pleasure
you know did you knew what happened to
me with uh
marvel comics
that was something
it's really something to see yourself
portrayed you know i got accused of
being a nazi pretty much when all this
happened it was really something because
i had been
teaching students
what we're talking about today about
these temptations that you faced and how
people as individuals get sucked into
that totalitarian hell you know and then
so that was something for that to happen
such a reversal and then to have that
comic book come out well it was surreal
it was absolutely surreal to be
portrayed
because nazi wasn't enough right we had
to go right for the archetype itself
so i think we've raised about four
hundred thousand dollars for charity now
on the basis of that so that was a fun
reversal
but it was really shocking when i first
saw that i i just couldn't believe it i
was very ill at the time too and i
thought this can't be real this has to
be photoshopped this cannot possibly be
happening it's so
completely beyond comprehension
and you know to come from the pen of one
of the foremost black intellectuals and
i i use the racial category only because
that's the categories that he's using to
operate with it
yeah
so
so life is really weird this is true
right
this is true
as this whole conversation illustrates
so
so what have been the personal
consequences for you of writing this
letter and and having it go
i mean yeah yeah i mean have you have
have you been pilloried has
what's happened to you
um
i haven't i haven't i haven't received
and this this is something that
i
don't think about so much actually
because i i prefer to just allow it to
be whatever it is right now to not
expect it or to it just is but i
actually have not received
any pushback
from this
and for it to have been read by over
four million people
and for me to not have been
aggressively dragged through the streets
of social media
you know by my neck it's
why not why hasn't it happened
why do you think what what's what's
operating to protect you do you think
you know what i
it would be very naive of me to think
that my identity markers the ones we've
been speaking about don't have anything
to do with that i think people are more
willing to listen to
what i'm saying because of the fact that
i'm black
if i had been white for example a lot of
what i'm saying the more universal
things that are not specific to me being
black or zimbabwean um
they would have just been dismissed
because there are many things people
have been saying over the past years
that are just common sense they make
sense people have genuine questions
but no one will listen to it because the
first thing they will see is that you
inhabit a white body so you don't get to
speak
you know
so i think people are more willing
um
to hear what i have to say because of
that and i think it's also because
i'm not preaching to anyone i'm not
telling
right i'm not an
academic i'm not trying to give you data
and
this is not about that this is a very
personal account from someone that has
been in it i'm not righteous i'm not
above you or below you
right this is just me
saying hey no i'm opting out of this
game and we all get to opt out
you know and i i think that's why it has
been received
very well because i'm speaking from the
eye i'm speaking from my own personal
experience and i think it can be very
hard to
dispute that
well see there's something interesting
about that too eh because one of the
mantras of of the left i hate to use
these categories but we're we're stuck
with it at the moment yes it is
you know the the the uh implicit truth
of subjectivity
and the thing is there's still yes right
and the thing is there's something right
about that
because
you are
there is a domain of knowledge
that you have privileged access to that
no one can dispute
and that domain of knowledge is
your honest representation of your
subjective experience
and that it does have the kind of power
that you just described
and so there is there's some sense in
noting that as a form of truth
but then it the claim seems to have got
twisted and perverted in some way which
which is it kind of gets elevated
narcissistically it's like because i
have this domain where i'm
i am the only person who has access to
those experiences
then all of a sudden that gets in it
gets inflated in this political way into
a narcissistic claim that you know
that means overall my truths are as good
as any truth and they're as good as
anyone else's
and there's an error there right because
there's despite the fact that there are
things that you can say that only you
can say that no one can dispute
there are all sorts of things that you
can't say that you don't know and that
are absolutely subject to dispute yes
and so it's it's it's the it's the
narcissistic inflation of the claim
beyond its reasonable boundaries and
then
your conscience i think was operating in
you to say
well where are the boundaries of this
claim like the
let's take the war so to speak between
black people and the and police in the
united states well obviously that's a
problem but it's a really really complex
problem
and maybe we want to have an instant
solution to it but we don't have an
instant solution to it and so
the claim is well this is a problem and
then the next claim is well it's based
in racism and then the next claim is
it's based in white supremacy it's like
well
wait a second
there's a problem here
and the problem with
coming up with the solution so rapidly
is
well you don't know
you actually don't know this is actually
a really complicated problem and your
intuition that it's a problem is is dead
on and your intuition that
it would be reasonably more reasonable
morally to be concerned about that is
dead on but the right approach is
questioning not
answering
and i think part of the reason that i've
got away with my lectures online i think
maybe and as a professor for that matter
is
i do my best to always question
and even my public lectures that on the
tour
i usually think of a question that i'm
trying to answer and then when i go out
and lecture i'm i'm trying to explore
the question i'm not telling the
audience what they should think i don't
know what they should think i don't even
know what i should think
and so i can guide them through the
process of exploration and and that that
seems to
well so far that seems to be working and
that's what we're doing in this
conversation and that's partly what
makes it a good conversation you know is
we're trying to figure something out
that we don't know
um yes oh i love that i love that and
yeah i i think that
directly speaks to
um
why my letter has
reached people in the way that it has
and it's received such a positive
reception overwhelmingly so i still
receive
hundreds of people messaging me every
single day emails
and
it's but you don't get the sickness from
that that you got with that other okay
so that's interesting too so how do you
know that this positive response is
credible
um
oh that's a very good question how do i
know that this positive
response is credible
it's a knowing that i don't quite have
language for
because the another reality of this is
that when you have so many eyes on you
and you know that something like this
is out there there is a discomfort that
comes with it um
but for me that discomfort is
adding to my well-being it's not taking
from my well-being so it's very it's
very difficult for me to sort of give a
neat answer to that but it's a it's a
very deep knowing and i'm sure you both
know what i mean by that and
that when i receive messages from people
in all corners of the world telling me
that my letter has freed them people
sending me voice notes crying
and saying that they you know they were
ostracized by their family members for
not supporting certain political
movements last year or not making
certain medical decisions that they
don't think were the best ones to make
etc etc because we're in a time where i
in my lifetime anyway we're more
polarized than i've ever seen before
it's it's so intense
um so the messages that i receive from
real life people
giving me specific accounts of what is
happening in their lives and how coming
across my words words that i didn't even
think were going to reach many people
um and that 4 million means something
and it's not just a to me it's not a
vanity metric of saying 4 million people
i couldn't give a [ __ ] about anything
like i really don't it's about what that
represents when i have people when i
have other black people telling me that
i've given them some kind of permission
slip to think deep differently you know
because as black people this is
something that i have to be honest about
especially in the west
we're not afforded the same level of
individuality as every everyone else was
sort of placed in the oppressed category
by default you know it's almost like you
have to fight for your individuality but
you
i say this in my lesson but like so
what's more what's the weight for what
is the weight of that so i mean
hypothetically right the theory is
well
we're trying to help you by defining you
as oppressed
right i mean that's the theory because
we see that well even if you use racial
metrics for example there's inequality
and so
the inequality is directed at you as a
racial group so the first thing you have
to swallow is that you should be
referred to primarily by your racial
group right to be the beneficiary of
that victim status so that's something
very insidious it's very insidious but
but you can give the devil as do and say
well there's some genuine concern there
too
but michaela
mentioned earlier how she felt when she
was placed in the oppressed category you
know briefly in a science class and it's
like you just said that you're in some
sense
burden with that struggling with that
all the time what's the cost of that
or is that what we're talking about
continually in this conversation that's
that is what we're talking about that is
what we're talking about and again i i
see all of these conversations quite
differently because
i wasn't born and raised here in the
western world so i have i i do have
something else to compare it to
and of course because of my geographical
location being in zimbabwe being in
africa where everyone around me is the
same i know i always say i
i found out that i was actually black
when i was nine years old when i came
here i didn't know that before i didn't
have to think about that i why would i
have had to think about that now
suddenly i'm hearing black black black
you're black you're this
oh you you like
you know motley crue
but you're black black people don't like
that or do you like led zeppelin
right i love led zeppelin oh yeah should
i yeah
definitely not definitely yes definitely
yes definitely
right so now there are suddenly all of
these
pre like this list of things that i
should and shouldn't like but they're
attached to my skin color so to me a lot
of this has always just been extremely
bizarre so i've never over identified
with any of those labels i do understand
their importance i really do i really
really do um and i i do know that
because of those identity markers i'm
treated in a certain way et cetera et
cetera but i don't over identify with
them in the way that some people wish i
did which i think was the issue of
everything that i've been experiencing
um
but yeah i i think i
just view a lot of this
very differently because
culturally it just doesn't make sense
for me to make my
quote-unquote blackness
the entirety of who i am it it just
it it doesn't it doesn't fit it doesn't
make sense it's certainly not an
accomplishment of yours
right right i mean it's not associated
with anything you've done good or bad
as an active agent
and so it's it's
it's it's hard for me to see
the advantage of that kind of
identification
it
and easy for me to see the disadvantages
right
okay guys we have to call it quits
that was an absolute honor to host both
of you i am so happy that we all got to
do this
uh before we go africa could you tell
people if they don't follow you
where they could go to follow you where
you are online
of course so my only social media at
this moment in time is instagram you can
find me at africa brook with an e at the
end
i have a lot of live conversations there
i do a lot of live podcasting i'm just a
curious person and i i allow myself to
do that publicly with all of you so you
can join me there if you want to find
out more about my work my website is
africanbrook.com
thanks guys that was that was really
cool it was a pleasure meeting you and
talking to you
very nice to meet you
and ut jordan thank you so much thank
you
[Music]
you